our doctor chair Andy rule is here with
the lessons that the US can learn from
how other countries are responding to
this outbreak Tara good morning
sometimes I wonder do they know
something we don't when we see they've
shut down their whole schools or
restaurants are empty but let's talk
about that drive-by program what can we
learn from that what impact does it
really have so this was really ingenious
and so creative and you know South Korea
took a lesson from what happened with
their experience with MERS back in 2015
where they really were not prepared and
so in in this you're able to basically
drive up have a sample taken within ten
minutes you're not exposing others to
potential infection and this gives you
really a broad big picture of the
disease and that's what you need you're
picking up a lot more cases and what
that allows you to do is get a more
accurate case fatality rate so you're
screening more people in additional
allows you to really isolate where the
infection is coming from so you can
better control it and it also allows you
to get treatment to people faster so
that broad-based screening is a really
big deal we don't have enough test kits
according to vice-president pants how do
we learn from other countries to better
manage our response here well we need to
start learning from other countries and
really speed is the critical thing you
know we know that even in general
medicine
the quicker you pick up on a disease the
quicker you can treat it and deal with
it and that is also the case with
epidemics and pandemics and so one of
the other things that other countries
have done a good job at is this concept
of social distancing so not congregating
in mass areas where you could
potentially get exposed you know in
South Korea they have a marketing
campaign now where they're saying you
know hold on let's not get social you
know so we have a lot to learn all right
Terra Thanks